play a quick game of never have I ever
80 for Brady edition first things first
never have I ever ghosted a guy
what's ghosted oh
and Jane's the one that hasn't no I
always married them never have I ever
had an edible damn it never raise your
hand if you've had gummies well okay
these are good very good oh careful
they're high dosage high dosage excuse
me I'm looking for someone are you okay
Guy Fieri never have I ever been to the
Super Bowl
I like watching
okay there you go that's our
Superstition she likes watching I'm a
home person you got it takes Jane to get
me out
never have I ever made out in a closet
no back seats no back seat back seat oh
I was good in front and back who in this
group do we think is the most flirty
Rita you pointing to Lily no well yeah
and I'm the sex one a sex person you are
I am yeah
we don't talk about it tell me the art
of flirting I've been told that uh men
uh react to you know the the slightest
warmth that a person would exhibit as a
human being to another human being like
if you reach out and touch you're
speaking and you touch someone's hand or
stand be arrested for that it was this
locker room scene that Rita says got her
all turned on at 90 years old but every
one of the ladies have their share of
fun in 80 for Brady hitting theaters
February 3rd the four besties are on a
wild mission to meet Tom Brady at the
Super Bowl
taken this one this is cute can we just
start with Tom is it really
really his presence just filled up the
whole trailer and I I got weak in the
knees yeah and he was so sweet he went
into all our trailers no he didn't go
into mine well that's because you went
to him I know I stood out there and
welcomed them all in you were the
welcoming Community
you know they're coming on our turf now
I would feel really scared if I were
going on football field to play football
um and so I stood out there and welcomed
him as they drove up hi I'm Sally can I
get you some clothes is that true or is
it because you are just a big sports fan
Sally that you wanted to be the woman
well I am a big sports fan that is true
and I did want to see them and shake
their hands but I also
recognized I I would feel really nervous
let's go oh my God
I'm ready did anybody else's knees get a
little weak with Thomas our knees have
troubles we have all we have knee issues
anyway
oh I have bad knees
nothing to do with Tom Brady
of course there's moments when you go
wow look at that person and then you
just get your act together
you married them in this case seriously
has it happened in your past any other
time yeah Marlon Brando
oh that's a whole nother story that's a
novella
yes I mean Burt Reynolds was no you know
he was pretty fabulous well yeah at
least we thought so on the outside from
the outside he was pretty fabulous he
was fabulous but I had to you know I was
an actor I have to like behave and I
worked with Paul Newman and trust me
that wasn't easy to go into it or you
table read with Paul and act like you
knew what you were doing I conquered it
by being really foul mouth
just as dirty talking as that possibly
could be I don't know this is a spicy
wings contest I could use a little spice
wrong okay so big thank you
Jane literally is is one person in my
life and I don't have many admittedly
who
um would not let me go I tried I tried
to knowing and she would just um early
on you know try to befriend me and when
I would back away she said well that
just time's up we're going out come on
every time I've had to talk about Jane I
end up crying because it had been so
incredibly important to me to have Jane
in my life that would do that and say
knock on my door call me and say okay
what time uh next Thursday will you meet
me at the okay and we always have a good
time and we always had a good time Jane
has been so important to me because of
that really isn't that what friendship
is that we Face the unknown together
Jane just won't take no for an answer
I've been fascinated with her since the
70s and I've you know I read all her
interviews I identify with her and I
just decided that I'm going to be her
friend she's going to be my friend and
that's all there is to it that's why for
me this film was really special because
I had never I mean I've watched every
performance multiple times of hers I've
seen her on Broadway asked her how she
did that now I got to see her I mean
it's a very different kind of film but I
got to see her create a character and
bring it to life and it was it was a
really special you know this is a light
funny movie but still I could see her
work I agree I think well first of all I
am a huge huge fan of Sally's Lord talk
about me yes listen excuse me
so CeCe we can do that anyway I
typically wanted to say corroborate in a
way that when I saw her in civil like my
jaw dropped for at least two months it
was my idea she stole it I wanted to
sing Easter Bunny really really bad
every time I thought of how she did that
she played you know a multiple character
person one person and she became these
different people and then there's this
one here who does it on stage who does
it on stage isn't she though and without
ever leaving the stage becomes all these
different people yeah how I wanted to be
civil
here's what I always remember
everyone of course talks about this the
astounding Talent as an actress but the
thing I saw around doing on stage that
absolutely put me away for a month Lily
yes was that she went from a squat on a
stage she went from a squat into a stand
on her leg I've never seen anyone do
that she you know what kind of size that
takes hey and that well that's a problem
we don't do that anymore I've never
forgotten this ready and action early on
in the movie in in the very early scenes
we were all working together and
everybody had to move very fast and be
in the right place at the right time and
turn the TV on like this and you know
having worked seven years with Lily I'm
I was used to kind of pushing her around
her you know like if she was a little
bit off her Mark or was like I'm sorry
she she
um right into that Rita I felt rid of
was was there was a problem because she
wasn't moving fast enough to recede so
that then Lily could come in and say and
so I pulled on her jacket and I think I
pushed her at one point
and I was offended and it was the
weekend and she sent me a text
and she said not on my watch I am 90
years old you do not treat me like that
this is a film about women's friendship
and that will not stand that kind of
behave you cannot push me and you cannot
do that and I was just oh that is so
great because you know what a guy would
have done he would have harbored a
grudge and she got it out and and didn't
Harbor it she's from Puerto Rico so it's
all in her heart and her emotions what
get it out perfect
[Music]